[Music]
hey guys welcome to other installments
of harry potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing the chamber of secrets lord
voldemort
and whether or not it would have ever
been possible for two of him to exist
simultaneously in the chamber of secrets
we see a much younger version of
voldemort
aka tom riddle inside of the chamber
this version of riddle was of course a
product of his first horcrux
the diary of tom riddle the ultimate
purpose of creating a horcrux
is to achieve immortality however the
truly sinister component of creating a
horcrux is that in order to produce one
you must
murder someone the diary of tom riddle
became horcrux
after voldemort murdered moaning myrtle
in 1943.
when harry enters the chamber he's met
with riddle
you you're the heir of slytherin you're
voldemort
surely you don't think i was going to
keep my filthy muggle father's name
no i fashioned myself a new name a name
i knew wizards everywhere would
one day fear to speak when i became the
greatest sorcerer in the world
minute by minute the tom riddle in front
of harry appeared more and more real
riddles seemed to grow stronger and
stronger assuming a more prominent
corporeal form
over time he achieved this by feeding
off of ginny
and her deepest and darkest fears she
put too much into the diary
into me enough to let me leave its pages
at last
riddle also later says yes potter
the process is nearly complete in a few
minutes ginny weasley will be dead
and i will cease to be a memory lord
voldemort will return
very much alive so that poses the
question
if tom middle had been successful in
killing ginny and assumed form of his
own
would there have been two voldemorts how
does that work
this confuses things a bit as the
half-blood prince references the diary
as a weapon to possess someone else to
work on tom riddle's behalf
while the chamber of secrets shows him
as being able to return to some kind of
independent form what would this mean
for each voldemort
the new younger form of him and the
wraith form of him that was lurking
around
the new riddle appears to be entirely
independent from the present day riddle
he has some concept of who the future
voldemort is
and some understanding of present-day
events but doesn't share the memories of
the new voldemort
as we know the purpose of a horcrux is
not to create a new individual
but to protect its creator from death
this is why the events of the chamber of
secrets
are unusual how could another person be
created
what intrigued an alarm to me most was
that the diary had been intended as a
weapon
as much as a safeguard said dumbledore i
still don't understand
said harry well it worked as a horcrux
it's supposed to work
in other words the fragment of soul
concealed inside it was kept safe
and had undoubtedly put its part in
preventing the death of its owner
but there could be no doubt that riddle
really wanted that tyre red
wanted the piece of his soul to inhabit
or possess somebody else
so that slytherin's monster would be
unleashed again well
he didn't want his hard work to be
wasted said harry he wanted people to
know that he was slytherin's heir
because he couldn't take credit at the
time the answer to the question of
whether two voldemorts could exist
is yes and no yes there would have been
two voldemorts present in the world
but no the new voldemort wouldn't be a
clone of the old voldemort
the two would still share a life force
and so the destruction of one
could mean the destruction of the other
however the most important thing to
remember
is the present-day voldemort would be
far too arrogant to accept that another
version of him
exists in the world one who is equal to
quote highlander
there can only be one jk rowling was
once asked what would have happened if
ginny had died and tom riddle had
escaped the diary
to which rowling responds i can't answer
that fully until all seven books are
finished
but it would have strengthened the
present day voldemort considerably
i think that from this we can assume a
couple of things
first that the wraith or original
voldemort was the master
and still held a certain amount of
control of the new voldemort
and second i think that it's likely that
had riddles succeeded in achieving a
second physical form
the master or wraith voldemort would
have combined his soul with the new
voldemort
they would once again share a physical
form voldemort likes to operate alone
remember i believe he would have found
the thought of being independent
even on the elixir of life intolerable
therefore i am convinced
he intended to continue to rely on his
horcruxes he would eat nothing more
if only he could regain a human form he
was already immortal you see
or as close to immortal as any man can
be
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please be sure to like
the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time you're a wizard harry
you